i
[Música]
en colombia cuando se cumplen 13 días de
manifestaciones en su mayoría pacíficas
diversas organizaciones de derechos
tanto nacionales como internacionales
han alarmado sobre el uso excesivo de la
fuerza por parte de la policía que deja
al menos 27 muertos según la defensoría
del pueblo unas cifras que ascienden a
47 según la ong independiente temblores
que también denuncian más de 1800 casos
de abuso policial y más de 500
desapariciones durante las últimas
jornadas las tensiones más violentas
están viviendo en cali la tercera ciudad
del país donde el domingo un grupo de
civiles armados bajo la presencia
policial disparó munición real contra la
minga indígena dejando al menos 8
heridos en este contexto el presidente
iván duque se traslado en una visita
relámpago a cali donde dio instrucciones
para un mayor despliegue de la fuerza
pública al tiempo que el expresidente
álvaro uribe llamó a la ocupación
militar para restaurar el orden mientras
los manifestantes y organizaciones
continúan de siéndole al gobierno una
reforma policial inmediata
[Música]
al menos 28 muertos en la peor masacre
de la historia de río de janeiro tras
una operación policial en la favela de
jacarezinho entre las víctimas un
policía y 27 civiles que según los
investigadores estarían relacionados con
el crimen
la operación perseguía a miembros del
comando vermelho la principal banda de
narcotraficantes que estaría empleando a
niños en el narcotráfico sin embargo los
primeros datos filtrados por la
procuraduría general muestran que sólo
tres de las víctimas tenían antecedentes
penales además la corte suprema- ha
avisado que ve un indicio de ejecución
arbitraria y ha pedido una investigación
independiente hay que recordar que desde
el año pasado estaban prohibidas las
operaciones policiales en favelas por
causa de la pandemia
además las naciones unidas- también han
pedido una investigación y han recordado
que brasil tiene un histórico con el uso
excesivo y desproporcionado de la fuerza
por parte de la policía
[Música]
en méxico en los últimos dos años han
sido frecuentes los casos de uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de
agentes policiacos uno de los casos más
fuertes ocurrió en mayo de 2020 cuando
el joven giovanni lópez de 30 años murió
a manos de policías de jalisco en el
marco de una manifestación precisamente
contra el abuso policíaco en el caso
georg floyd más tarde en noviembre de
ese año la policía de cancún dispersó a
balazos una manifestación feminista y
resultaron heridas dos personas ya en
este 2021 el caso más sonado sin duda es
el de la migrante salvadoreña victoria
salazar una mujer que murió a manos de
la policía de tulum en quintana roo y
dejó huérfanos a dos adolescentes cuatro
policías de tulum ya fueron vinculados a
proceso pero la violencia no para en
abril pasado se hizo viral un vídeo que
circuló en redes sociales donde se ve a
policías de puebla someter con uso
excesivo de la fuerza a un adulto mayor
el gobierno calificó este hecho como
brutalidad policiaca y ya se investiga
[Música]